everyone has a different point of view
look at a survey economist and the
expectations for growth this year very
pretty widely I think there is a general
recognition that things have stabilized
that there is some optimism that you'll
see growth by the end of this year that
will pick up next year I haven't heard
anyone who's anticipating strong growth
next year hoping for just modest growth
we'll see from there the real question
is what prompts sort of real strong
growth going forward and that's an
interesting question I happen to believe
that when you look at the history of
these ten previous bleak periods that
what actually brings us out of these
periods and produces the kind of strong
recovery that I think most people would
like is some form of major innovation
and you can go back in history sometimes
it was technological and whether it's
the Internet in the 1990s it was the
Erie Canal in the 1820s railroads in the
1840s new forms of mass production in
the 1910s all of which followed to one
of these major contractions the real
question for us is what is that next
thing that has the capacity to change
psychology to get people focus on the
future again to create a sense of
confidence Bay and also at the same time
create new industries thousands of new
companies what is that next thing I
suspect it should be around climate
change and associated incentives for
alternative energy and energy efficiency
but we'll have to see what Congress and
the administration do later this year on
that
in the last six months we would add 1800
new firms as customers it's just
incredibly telling about the dynamism of
the financial system and i use a was
probably a kind of bad metaphor but i
really see the financial system as kind
of like forest and in that force the
tallest trees may wither poeple limbs
may fall off but what you're seeing is
the seedlings beginning to sprout up
everywhere all over the world and that
is to me the greatest hope that is the
best sign of optimism and fundamentally
what it is is entrepreneurs innovators
with new ideas out there taking risks
that hasn't stopped and as long as that
doesn't stop over time we'll be fine we
will be absolutely fine and there will
be recovery just as there has been in
every single one of these major
downturns in the past